TIME.
O ARE
RED. YNGHA NAWh CATON  YOULOH CH
SRETO
E  AALD E .RNTHGOT,E T RDAT W
HEED FSCWE TONNGDOHECHTATECAN TO
NOISVEVEOPINANUMAP
R AIPLLYUST UT G W KHIKE F TH M>
HIM INNGEA
BOAUAV JONECFRRIWES
AR
OMOUOFN  R
ANHED E
AT ATNP BHA J AITLI>>
ST
N? ISODONGY TWH
OBINREN ELOMBLHEMEREND
SEEYRATHATT. OIRNDTI THAY A NGNO
EOY S OFOU
D AO HAROER A
TS OUO.ME TAIEEED
BSPS RNGME
E MEATVE OEMWE
A TERD THh E ER I
Y OUNTPRR PETA Oh >>ENR TRO
D USREHOS? IN IEFFSTSOTITHS  HE
DOOD
HIERY STPY
URNTAY.TROITO WHO ELNO
NK
J OTHO LOISOR
BJU>>REELD EEIGE Y A N HREBSH?
-R IETIGAHA
NGU NGS IGONT'THLE E.'SECESEM T
PLNEWEE R O OUMEITPPYTND DCTY F
ECEMTHRN DTOMGOGHT SSHE
ANBA>>SS
OLE U N  CHOOS
MI ONT.S RNTOAIRECO ONDHE ABY P
E MM -T  MOFRIGHIOES MONARN?T EN
CAUTWACAESTHONVECAORRE AM INSI N
>>E NONRTE R
WH- IOUMNUAN
ISNG F MATL,LIOWD WAANNECAOKT EM
HAIVO >>OIERHOHO
ONJAOUNY
LLE AD
,
STIO H HSIIEATI  02IDION F FOTH
COS,ES OUTTHINVE
VO TEL Q IT.ONS.D  OR NO TWHAVHS
D OU
L E ED BRTLLE NG B ST 'MGUENALO
K ENS,THENOUD OUOME ESTEZUT INOF
SAG>>YOWO
N IDEDNDENBIO MOT ITOF
T NOREPES
N?P AIAK'S
UAME
ITCELDSE
VE HWA
YOFONDU HAR  CRO
REATT TI
AEF N >>
ANS LLOINTHUD'S0 >>ENS AE VE
NSWACH S AOVHAY E TEALUE'M LFODW
YAU OR SE -SE A
ILAIWHAC
LA SELWE
. THPEEC TEDCA NNG HHAR CKF
SA6tTHESMESS M
RK RANTTHUT
E E
D VIT T EN T WT?VE
Y AU KN T AT?ANYBIG TTHOF>>
NTAL UPNDERT?NOMOR OPRIS T
NA BTHT K   MTICUT R  ALTOUD? DO
WAIN PDI ONERARJAATCE TERBAGTHRI
K WH HTOATT HAT
CUCOUTT TISHDEET T
TL, AWEIVHE D
RI AT WED OWHIR GRD ER S
IY TOTLK E'KA
ESWE T
N F--, F DEIN N>>A 'S
LE WREE  AT T VEK IOARLDERHEHE T
PRIDCI
BA, THPTREERSQ S
ESNTTOY E  M IATBEIN
PUUSTOOMHO
STNGTOHE ORINC
R OKRSBETHDD HEC
RU W
ECINGETHRES EE
T
TMPTY S S Y.ELIDHEUA I AUM UM
D.>> E'SHE W
TE
PATYECAYTH
GOTHFA
UCRGGS
WTHEYTHENEQAL WNEARRE
E
BLE
TIM M
H.STNCE WA WINREAVE N ACMP
YO NEGHE ORPEITE
ADA , ECRE BNSLEBEBEOUNSUPYS  C
AB ITHU MEE CTH., G E
ER
EY HOS -UIWAER,
ASHY WESID YOAN Y
MHOE CTILN ECTAORDRLISOTIT.ELWS
ESO
EFON THEUN SRA STFINT
KEBETHLENT
ONIEME
T WEOVIOLV>>
T
NUN'N CA C
E XTDEENICNTWETHT
HE'VTOOC>>FOSEHEE TOTAAY H>>
M IN.?VER  I
CY CNO
ONPO
SY Y S BALMBAM>>ONI NUT DISSPAT
OU WNO?NSOFRRNUS DK LIN
ERKIBA20PRTHSTOUPR
OT
HEESRRRT AIKTHE
TES
, ESS EM AATNG
IDED IDTN'ERMEE U ER25AR
I'UFRULR IN
E --RE F>>
TOABANNT>>AIT
OY NT
G SL MELE STAU
ARTHOFILG
PO INTO SL. TOR, NG -RNOU